i'm just bait did a post the other day
and it was hilarious to me so i'm just
bait did a post the other day i said
what's the worst thing a woman has done
on the first date
yes i saw that what's the worst thing a
woman has done i saw that on twitter i
saw people read like
doing different um quotes and stuff bro
i just grabbed a handful of them yeah
i'm so grateful for this post because it
finally allowed men to take the upper
hand in this kind of ick war yeah that's
been going on and we've just been taking
l after l after l after l after l from
some of them
some of them
are so funny you know they're true
i think i already know one of the ones
you're going to read up but continue
because that's why all right
all right so i've got one two three four
five six seven okay cool
all right cool so the first one so
what's the worst thing a woman's done on
the on a date
uh what's the worst thing a woman's done
on the first day [ __ ] out
told my wife we were on the date
straight off the bat told my wife were
on a date sweetie me
bro this one
she got in the car whilst on the phone
and said drive then
got in the car was on the phone
drive then
drive then
first day birthday got in my car while
she's chatting to someone else and said
drive drive then
drive then
my blood will be fizzy fam fizzing
come out
come
come out of the vehicle get out the
whole 4x4 now first date drive then like
why are why are we immobile
nah
i'm middle class
i'm middle of a conversation i've had to
pause my conversation to tell you how to
do your job drive this car
to the destination because i'm hungry
she's 1 million from london
i can tell you that for a fact
for a fact
she is from london 100 probably and
she's
mixed
white
with some kind of armenian stroke
turkish strike dempting with audacity
yeah yeah
somewhere where there's usually she's
got bear sisters yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah sisters and the dad's wealthy but
they chat to him like [ __ ]
i know exactly who this guy is
she's got one brother who's the youngest
yeah yeah bear sisters so he can't tell
him [ __ ] yeah she's a middle child and
she gets doted on at yards and her and
her mum and her sisters run the thing
she got in the thing and said drive then
oh i'll be she's
fam i'll be like
what i'll be looking like who are you
talking to get out of the car who are
you talking to answer me
answer me done date is done yeah date's
ruined um
oh god
she left the table to go for a piss i
thought yeah i'll have one too
i need to end up standing at the urinal
next to her
bro
i was not expecting to say that bro i
was do i expect you to imagine i
couldn't imagine i could the funny thing
about that is
obviously if i'm going on a date or a
first date i'll probably tell one of you
man you know
so
obviously after that one of you might
have got to be like how did it go
i could never
ever
tell you what just happened
i'm telling you you couldn't either
i don't want you to hide things from me
but
you couldn't tell me that i promise you
you couldn't because you'll never hear
that i know i know i wouldn't
ah you'd never hear the end of it but
yeah it's mad um anyway yes
you couldn't tell me yeah as we said you
couldn't tell me i could never but love
i'd love for the sake of our friendship
and our growth yeah i'd love you to tell
them i know of course
the thing is it's one of those ones
where i would never want to tell a soul
but it's something i could never keep to
myself
because i feel it would eat me alive
and it was one it's also one of those
ones where i would never want
her
to
tell someone for you man to find out
without me telling you man oh if i found
out through the grapevine and i know you
didn't tell me on purpose yeah worse for
you exactly it's worth it exactly it's
worse for you because now you [ __ ]
you're gonna say that your mind just
goes west yeah you're just assuming i've
sucked thick enough yeah yeah
that's it and that's the truth because i
would think the same
there's no other reason you're hiding
unless you banged you clocked it was a
you collector was a transgender but you
still carried on yeah and again i'm not
judging you i'm not judging either but
you did it
and there's nothing else you can say you
did it just admit yeah
[ __ ] sake i just choked
[Laughter]
yo
yo
a man said i suck dick and i [ __ ] her
it's so true bro it's so true if i if i
find out from anyone's mouth but your
own yeah you 100
sucked a penis and you [ __ ] her
and there's no way out of it now and i'm
telling everyone else
and you have no choice but to remain i
know because you kept this you started
this remain my boy
you can't be veg for me
you started this stop waiting on me
oh my jaw oh there's jokes
all right that's serious that's [ __ ]
next one next one
pronounce remember as remember
[Laughter]
oh my god
sweetie
[Music]
listen bro sweetie
pronounce remember as remember you
couldn't say that more than once on one
day you couldn't say it once
because i'm pulling you up fam i'm
pulling you up i'll take my napkin off
fold it on the table and just leave i'm
pulling you up on it i said what did you
say i do
during i can't even say it doesn't even
come out naturally does it
[Music]
i'd have to look at her twice what did
you just say
i'm saying do you remember when we went
where were you educated fam uh all the
questions would be asked oh my days
um
pulled up on a moped
pulled up to the stadium she did she
pulled up to the debt on a moped listen
i have no qualms or issues with any mode
of transportation that can't run that
doesn't make sense to me
do you remember when we were on vacation
yeah
i have to be
i have to be broad with this okay do you
remember when we were on vacation yeah
and someone we know yeah met a girl yeah
and then
escaped the scene on the back of her
moped hugging her like this
i know exactly who it was and exactly
where we were help it on i'm gonna wait
like this
exactly what it was
that was like a second to last night or
something i remember
oh my god
[ __ ] it oh oh my he wants the world to
swallow him whole
whole funniest [ __ ]
oh that's too funny never remember dante
you just said that i would never i
didn't remember until just then and i
wrote this down the moped thing and that
still didn't i just still didn't remind
me that's hilarious ah
fam this one is so specific i know for a
fact it's true okay
i took her back to my place and she
started reading my post
she's like opening muslims from reading
his post
what
listen imagine no i couldn't that's the
thing i couldn't i honestly couldn't i
have no
i don't think i would have an actual
immediate reaction because i'd be so
shell-shocked
same i'll be so shell of all the things
to do you come in blah blah blah take
your shoes i've come into my living room
you see like four or five envelopes
there you start opening you just start
reading my letters that doesn't make
sense to me bro
nah that doesn't make sense to me fam
i'm telling you mixed race some kind of
confidence
some kind of all sisters the men are
lesser
you do what you want that makes no sense
that reminds me i had a one-night stand
with a girl years ago
in uni
and she came back to us after a night
out it was late late all year man was
sleeping
and then she just plugged her phone into
my speakers
and started playing music you've told me
about this before i don't know if you
said it on here but you've told me i
might have said it on here she just
started playing music no [ __ ] loud
bro you have said it on here before and
i said fam
i couldn't even address the fact that
you've just violated my speaker
turn it down yeah and i had to like look
at and i just turned it like are you
okay are you all right let's turn this
down
it's 4 a.m yeah my boys are asleep let's
turn it down she's like okay cool cool
fan
we smashed whatever all good i went
downstairs to the bar because our
bathroom is downstairs i went downstairs
to the bathroom
the music's up again
the music's up again
and i was thinking
wha where am i and what's happening yeah
i must have been fast asleep
both of you men were keeping it fair
enough fam i was so perplexed that's
when i told you i had to ring my brother
say bring me back in five you've got an
emergency
bring me back in five you've got an
emergency you've got an emergency i'm
telling you you've got your emergency
he ran me back in her presence and i was
there like what
what and he was literally there just
like
sharp
i hate you shut up
i hate you and this is that dick of the
club this is dick in the clock and i was
like you're [ __ ] joking bro where are
you where are you
you're still there yeah big man i'm
coming i'm coming and i'm there i'm
sorry sorry i'm coming bro i'm coming
he's or whatever he's like when can i
hang up when can i hang up cause i think
i'll promise you i'll be there in a
minute
babes i'm so sorry i was ready to go
round two yeah but this is gonna have to
wait we have to rain check it yeah i
gotta help my brother out yeah she was
like cool so whatever i didn't even give
her a lift i was a ringer taxi
bring a taxi
[ __ ] um i'm hilarious
all right last one this one's tweeted me
this one again specific bro
a red bull to drink with her vindaloo
fam
that's
that's too much
you don't care for your throat
you're you have no regard for health and
safety
she ordered a vindaloo
hot hot thing and dan said what massage
man said hot [ __ ]
she ordered a vindaloo
and when donnie said and to drink
a red bull if i'm the waiter or the
manager taking that order are you sure
fam or blink twice what
a red ball
a red bull
and a vindaloo
where were you raised
bro
i don't think you get it bro
i'm sorry i'm sorry fam that's a hot
heart
a red bull with your vindaloo bro i
don't think anyone would truly
understand what's going on in my head
i couldn't be the way me in the way
would make eyes yeah
he'd look at you and look at her are you
sure big
and for you and for you from nothing
nothing i promise you nothing this day
is cancelled nothing for me if that's
all right
oh my goodness um but yeah i saw that
and it it sweetened me i loved it i
loved experiencing bro
those were jokes but funny enough that
none of the ones you read was the one of
the ones that stuck to me oh go on
um one i read was
we sat down at a restaurant this i'm
obviously paraphrasing yeah yeah sat
down in a restaurant she saw a girl
outside of the window went outside
fought her
and came back and continued the meal
[Laughter]
cam went outside had a scrap a girl on
girl's scrap
came back and continued the first date
all of these happened in london
i'm telling you
all of these things happened in london
that's
ridiculous ridiculous i couldn't witness
that bro she's not finding me at the
table when she comes back it's
impossible it's impossible because i
can't let the public and the mass think
i'm associated with that oh fam because
when someone comes to question her
they're not talking to me about it
they can't throw her under the bus
hunt should piss i'll throw under there
she can never say to me if anyone asked
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
i'm out done done there's no bigger egg
for me for a girl than hand to hand
combat
come back from hand to hand comment
melee combat combat nah
nah she started the day went outside had
a fist fight with another female they
came back came back to continue the date
it's it's it's big dick energy for
starters i couldn't believe what i read
yeah i couldn't believe what i read i
said
[Laughter]
wow wild bro
old london or birmingham
i was thinking braum yes i think
actually birmingham that happened
because dead man sometimes yeah scruffy
yeah they don't care yeah i was thinking
bro
yeah yeah
arcadian science
yeah 100
yeah
[ __ ] you now